[Music]
can you share with us one strange or
unique fact about you
no one strange or unique fact about me
is I hate when my face is wet I hate it
there was like nothing worse for me it
makes me super uncomfortable so when I
was about ten years old I was riding a
go-kart and I had my head back on a twig
broke off and got bent through my nasal
passage and it was stuck there for about
three days and one day sneezed really
hard and a little bit of it came out and
I pulled and then I saw a little 3-inch
little sapling today it was nuts
still have a twig I've never taken a nap
in my entire life never not once I have
very strange passion for snakes
I love reptiles reptiles are like my
everyday life they're my go-to my like
healthy coping mechanism if I'm feeling
down stressed or unhappy I take
herpetology on my high school high tech
high Chula Vista and it's my most
favorite class in the world and most
people see snakes is like oh my god evil
serpents are from hell they're poisonous
don't touch them but in reality we just
really chill animals who are really
beautiful and I have a lot of
appreciation and respect towards them
[Music]
one leg is longer than the other how did
you clean that up
I found it out like just shoe shopping
and then one shoe would never fit and
then you know realize that one leg is
longer one foot is longer I was born in
a house instead of a hospital on purpose
or an accident um yes it was probably
both because my mom hated doctors so she
just put it off until it was too late
I occasionally sleep with my eyes open
and people can tell if I'm really awake
or really asleep it's hereditary I have
this scar on my forehead from when I got
into cracks when I was four years old
and when they say citrusy boto and are
you're gonna go through the windshield
that's actually true because I went
through in show yeah yeah Google a
democracy and then when its back into
the air which other strange fact about
myself
I have alopecia areata which cause my
hair fell out it's an autoimmune
disorder that causes the attacks your
hair follicles and causes them all to
fall out so I shaved the side and
bleached my hair like this
thank you thanks I try I've been to
almost all 50 states I'm at 47 right now
I don't know I think that's it I have
broken all of my fingers except for my
thumbs and I can play with my thumb I
don't know it it does this move it's a
strange fact for me unique why are you
laughing so it's like it is like
something that I find really like I can
pop out my shoulder blade a little bit
can't really tell them this shoot comes
out I could make my face look like an
ogre
I have a webbed toe on my right foot
let's me swim faster than Aquaman I can
eat an entire box of cheez-its in under
30 minutes that's probably like my most
interesting fact it's pretty solid I
don't like sweet like I've never I don't
know if anyone else thinks that's weird
but to most of my family and friends
it's weird that I like don't like any
type of food I don't know what it is I
like vegetables I was born in Ukraine so
that's the kind of strange in what's
strange about that is that I've lived
here for 17 years and my parents still
don't speak English I like to play
devil's advocate in debate or certain
topics when I'm talking to certain
people it could be about any kind of
random topic political and not social
and/or personal it really doesn't matter
but I kind of like to play like the
other side to kind of get people out of
their comfort zones and kind of explore
the other side of a conversation or just
kind of live through it alternate
alternative reality almost that's like
one unique or I say weird thing
I guess that a tornado hit my town
I have pretty severe PTSD from it I
should be dead like it was given a death
sentence three times and I beat it all
when nobody else did so yeah can you
explain that mom I have an autoimmune
and a muscular and a genetic disorder
and it popped up and almost killed me
when I was 13 and they pretty much told
me I was gonna die and I said no you
would never believe how old I actually
am a lot of people think I'm 20 years
old I'm actually taking eight I like the
movie pretty in pink that's pretty
strange why do you like it I don't know
just the storyline it's pretty awesome
that's what yeah pretty much it I never
seen it pretty in pink yeah it's about
this basically this girl all right so
basically this girl she lizard their dad
and I'm trying to remember it and
she's going for like the super-rich guy
no way the rich guy like kind of likes
her but she's like super like before
whatever so she like has to hold like a
couple jobs and then there's this other
guy named ducky which is kind of like a
punk rock dude yeah and he likes her
like really likes her but she doesn't
like him because that's like her best
friend okay so that's why the rich white
guy okay but he's actually pretty sweet
so okay ends up being pretty cool yeah
that's why fry my strange weird Dan yeah
yeah you have to it's pretty gay
[Music]
what's up guys my name is Raya and I'm
the owner of this channel I'm also the
person behind the camera and I thought
I'd take a minute to thank all the
subscribers I've gained so far and maybe
ask the new years to hit the subscribe
button if you liked this episode or if
you're a fan of my channel in general I
mean lon thank you